poison ivy has been through a lot in the  last year and a half in this series  she's going on a road trip  with a mission  [Music]  she kind of walks a very fine line  between a classic villain and kind of an  anti-hero  what it ends up being  is really a love story from the  perspective of a villain harley quinn  and ivy i think are one of the biggest  fan favorite relationships in the whole  bad verse and i think fans of both of  the characters will be pleased we try to  undo some of the ivy myths that have  developed over the years is she a  carnivore what does she think about  environmentalism as it exists today  marcio just took some of these ideas  that i had in the script and pushed them  all the way to their logical conclusion  if you read this first issue you'll see  what i mean  but there's something coming that iv  does not expect and can't control  [Music]